what's up you guys it's Wednesday
yeah we just saw um blood shot last
night yeah we did it was pretty good it
was it was actually better than I was
expecting
yeah Vin Diesel being this Vin Diesel II
as he could possibly [ __ ] be and no
one can be more Bend easily than the
diesel yeah I mean you know I'd be
willing to be if you think you can be
more Vin Diesel let me know but I doubt
it very much it was like $19.99 for a
long time it went down to $6.99 on Xbox
on 4 HD and SD all-in even 4k so I was a
fan of the of the Riddick series I
really liked it and so we'll watch this
one you know and this might be his best
movie maybe we we did a review of it
really
yeah we'll review it on the matinee show
on Sunday so I recommend it yeah the
price is right on it and it's you know
it's a good movie it's like something
out of the damn Marvel Universe Connor
but it's a little bit different yeah
it's still like a comic it started off
you know there he's like in Mumbai and
just the way it's shot I didn't really
get a good impression of it the first
like 5 minutes he was in the damn kind
of like a [ __ ] tactical uniform you
know military type [ __ ] uniform and I
was expecting [ __ ] sensei to [ __ ]
walk around a corner any minute it
looked like it was gonna be a Steven
Seagal style [ __ ] movie and I was
just waiting for [ __ ] him you know
his ass to [ __ ] his fat ass to come
around the [ __ ] corner looking for
don't ya ya out for doughnuts that I
know I know you think you're Vin Diesel
and I know you think you can go in there
and take all these guys wants but I know
better
we're gonna have to give you an Asian
experience yeah and you never know what
race [ __ ] Seagal he's gonna be black
or he's gonna be [ __ ] a Cajun or he's
gonna be [ __ ] Italian or Nate
American or he's gonna be [ __ ]
Japanese [ __ ] he's a man of the world
yeah I know you're gonna try to van I
know you're gonna be try to be a man in
your own movie but you can never be a
man in your own movie when I'm around
[ __ ] like that
imagine imagine if you had [ __ ] vid
Deedle Vin Diesel em [ __ ] is it an
incest a in the same [ __ ] movie well
now we need to make that happen
yeah actually I would pay a substantial
amount of money to see Vin Diesel like
to see like Steven Seagal come up to Vin
Diesel and have that conversation
there's Vin Diesel go squish I think I
think [ __ ] sensei might be bigger than
VIN VIN hi it's hard to say it's hard to
say I watch it we're gonna make it
commercial yeah before you get in that
pool though I want you go in there and
shave you crack I don't want to affect
taste he's gonna pour it back into the
cab yeah yeah yeah I mean way we can
reseal these tabs
I gotta have [ __ ] Segal on to me show
[ __ ] more now somebody needs to send
us the Steven Seagal bobblehead so they
can have that one and then him and
Beatty cake and have a little
conversation and you can do both sides
that you can do excuse me madam I I
don't know I don't know you don't really
know your name but I can just tell by
the way you stand and you might be
suffering from breast cancer I happen to
be she had some fourth degree shiatsu
master and these hands
certified can find breast cancer within
20 minutes so if we just stand over here
and you open your blouse for me out I'll
go ahead and don't get this down free of
charge
hold on let me so I need my film crew
here to document this whole documentary
yeah my abilities the five breast cancer
[Laughter]
does that mr. Miyagi things like this
[ __ ] hot Baghdad the fact that he
actually said that people like it all
seriousness like thinking that people
are gonna go okay sure
this just shows how [ __ ] clueless
even I get a [ __ ] call for [ __ ] ago
mr. Ross I hear you keep [ __ ] with me
on your damn program I know where you
live [ __ ] tries to whip my ass Jenny
gets out the camera well yeah I totally
would
yeah you know me I mean like you're us
you you'll be all right you'll be all
right kick his ass come on yeah and he
comes out to be running like a [ __ ] man
she does around like a [ __ ] little
skinny arms that was a thing always
amazed me about [ __ ] sensei he's
doing all this [ __ ] I [ __ ] they told
me you know like [ __ ] when I was in the
army some guys yeah he was a Navy SEAL
then he took his jacket off I looked at
his arms I was like no Co no really then
I saw him run I went no [ __ ] way I
was like I said anywhere many people
have commented on the weird way that
Iran ya know you would never survive the
military running like that running like
that that's like that Japanese samurai
run but I can't step forward they can't
step forward did you just the legs kick
out in the back they move forward
somehow they just tilt forward and then
just start making a little scurry so
weird
I can't even I don't even know if I
could do that there's anyone on my face
there's a [ __ ] Japanese name for that
samurai style of running yeah yeah like
I said I didn't run him without stepping
forward which is amazed
amazing you think then they would just
run backwards yeah yeah if it's impolite
to step forward to just turn around
backwards and just write backwards
problem
[Laughter]
yeah SSA what the tactical meeting of
that [ __ ] Japanese rod is yeah
understand stiff he would know he knows
everything when you're running with a
sword it's very dangerous you don't want
your legs to step out from the blade I'm
sure he'd come up with someone yeah yeah
like I do like I thought it was because
the samurais were this big long dresses
like just come on oh yeah well you know
what I mean it's like a skirt rope no
they just they just didn't how to run so
it's like maybe maybe it's like getting
in that way maybe they should like do
like a you know they should do it
shorter in the front yes I did because
okay and I feel bad because like I
forgot like I wanted to UM thank Neil a
I hope I pronounced that right again
because they sent me another PayPal
donation yeah it's a big dude and that
was like a couple days ago and I meant
to mention on the show and then I kept
forgetting because like I don't know we
kept going off on different tangents and
whatnot so I just forgot to mention it
so I did want it like mention again I'll
probably I'll mention it on the main
show too but um you know on the next one
but you know I always like to shout it
out close to the day that it happened
also listen this weird show you guys so
I you know as I've mentioned on here
before I you do a 3-mile like my little
power walk out there in the morning
right and I usually go out around 7
o'clock and um I see all kind of like
little critters sometimes I see deers
always like squirrels and birds and
hawks and [ __ ] like that then yesterday
I'm walking and I'm walking and I see
like next to the path there were these
two little brown lumps like at first I
thought is that it bear turds I thought
it was bear turds because there's bears
running around out there too and every
now and then you see like a little pile
of bear [ __ ] good news is a bear [ __ ] on
the path he does um so I get closer it
was too low
moles yeah I have never seen bulls
running around
above the ground before yeah like it was
just two of them and they were just so
farting around in the dirt like and then
like I walked up to him and they were
like oh [ __ ] and they like cheesed it
into the [ __ ] bushes which I thought
was like really weird like the only time
I've seen it honestly the only time I've
seen a mole around here is when Beijing
rocks at one yeah okay grab that [ __ ]
mole ran up to me like that reared up on
her back legs to show to me to slant it
down the grass WWF yeah that way what
the [ __ ] it was like trying to claim it
try to impress this we like her Oh mole
wrestling prowess yeah she was only that
big when she did it they're so [ __ ]
funny yeah that but yeah it's just it
was just like so [ __ ] weird and I
don't think I ever saw one I just never
saw them really run around cuz usually
is [ __ ]
yeah come on brother day we saw
armadillo - yeah like an remember those
kids were like wanting to go over and
touch it because it was like a family
walking past and they're like oh hey -
stop them they're like don't touch the
aramid no I do not have to do it don't
touch that thing those are dirty oh yeah
this is it's like a maggot all right
it's just a four-legged matter cute and
everything but you know carry leprosy
and [ __ ] yeah here's my armadillo story
I was direct one time I was down
Mississippi I was driving to the [ __ ]
deer woods I had a new rifle I was gonna
[ __ ] shoot you know the target
shooting and stuff and if I saw a dead
deer in the middle of the road somebody
read over so I slowed down to go around
it and as I went around it it moved it
was and I was like what the [ __ ]
zombie deer belly moved in his [ __ ]
ass one and a pop and a [ __ ]
armadillo popped out of its ass running
yeah I was like whoa call my dad about
he's like yeah they do that when they're
not Rodney crawl up inside to a sweat
sauce off and study
that's where the good stuff is hey you
got any date that just amuses the [ __ ]
out of me I said honestly if I could do
animation somebody should do an
animation of like a little armadillo
like going up and crawling into a deer's
butt hole and like in there coming out
all like all like excited yeah popped
out man and I almost let her to pop ran
out because the deer wasn't robbed and
it was fresh yeah it was up in there
getting some DEET
I know it was like all-you-can-eat
buffet and yeah just get such a bad rap
they are awful cute though but yeah
there are four legged mag they're
carrion eaters yeah probably better not
to like touch them cuz they carry on
you're blind in the candy here they
don't they can't see or hear you can
walk right up to one gonna be like are
you in there's bottles no there's a big
one one time I [ __ ] walked up to a
head of machete my hand Bobby wait Pete
and [ __ ] jumped about five feet high
hit the ground running didn't even
[ __ ] put a scratch on it
well yeah that's tried to kill it with a
net with a why'd you do that I was a kid
about 13 you know 13 14 and I was I
might kill it it was big though you know
it wasn't a baby one yeah without the
tail it was probably almost 2 feet long
holy [ __ ] a big full-grown one
yeah and I hit it and it peaked and then
[ __ ] ran and did it it didn't even
put a dent in it yeah they got good
[ __ ] armored yeah yeah it's like
hitting a turtle when they're eternal in
our backyard the other day yeah yeah big
box turtle pokey went up and looked at
it smelled it went on boy's mouth you
sure that's dirty
she usually likes stinky things I left
it out there and a [ __ ] it was a big
box turtle you know about a foot long
and then went back out there five
minutes later is gone didn't even say
you know suck it forward [ __ ] to that
they go yeah cuz they're really slow
yeah maybe he went into another
I just thought it would be I thought it
would be funny if like Pookie would jump
on the back and like ride him around
yeah she walked up to it real conscious
real consciously and smelled the back
feet and went oh thank you you know for
me yes fearless she loves sticky stuff
all right you done for you don't forget
all right we got to do that shirt quick
this [ __ ] there's another [ __ ] shut
the door yeah that's what you can do
when you go out of the office you yank
my door and do that all right so you
guys have a good rest of your Wednesday
and as always we'll talk to you again
tomorrow